we're here to have fun and make food for
people hey guys I'm Anthony porosity
from Netflix's queer I and I'm here to
teach you how to make solitude Dini so I
learned about this recipe on a treadmill
at 8 or 9 p.m. when I was at the gym and
I was watching one of my favorite people
in the world Giada De Laurentiis
and she was making this it's actually a
Napolitano classic doing 40 minutes of
some kind of cardio which is terrible if
I'm watching a good show an hour can go
by very quickly and before you know it
you've burned 900 calories and you know
exactly what you want to make for dinner
that night so it's kind of like a double
whammy
Bailey's are so important it's just a
layer of depth you'll never taste
anything and be like oh yeah this is
like really Bailey for you right now it
just makes it taste like Grandma that's
what it is don't stress out we're just
making food we're not saving lives Ted
Allen taught me to put parmesan rinds in
my sauces you just bury it in and it's
just gonna flavor it with its goodness
and even just 30 to 40 minutes of this
and that's that's really all that you
need we have our bay leaf parmesan rind
and the basil which kind of doesn't get
much more Italian than that but those
are the three things that you also want
to remember because we're gonna be
removing those as well
we're using our boreal rice which is a
very short grain and might I add very
accessible rice grain as well that I
don't think is used that often and
people think that it's only for risotto
and we're gonna cook this the way you
would regular rice it really couldn't be
simpler that's the thing with this dish
I want to show that you can make
something that looks so beautiful and
complex but the essence of it is really
it's if you break it down it's actually
very simple and anybody can make it
food was never really something that I
planned on pursuing in a professional
capacity
I had toyed with the idea in the past
but I had sort of other ideas of what I
thought my life should look like and
because I think cooking is such an
intimate thing it's something that I do
on a personal level in my relationship
from my friends from my loved ones that
I never really associated it with sort
of like a public thing that I could
actually work on or make a career out of
my father my mother would travel and
they would go all over the world and
they would come back with these amazing
recipes that they would try out on us
the thing is with my mother she's such a
perfectionist in the
kitchen not unlike me I was actually
never allowed to participate in the
cooking and I'm the same way I don't let
anybody help me with my prep for any of
it
so I kind of understand where she was
coming from so I would sort of sit at
the other end of the counter and just
watch her prepare everything and I
learned very much by studying it which i
think is actually a really good way to
go about it because you really get to
pay attention to the details by actually
watching it you get to see things that
sometimes you won't learn during the
conventional lesson so with the
mozzarella here what I'm doing is by
tearing it into really smaller strands
it's gonna be a lot easier for it to
melt we want it to really be sort of
like melty and oozy and have that effect
so this is perfect consistency it's
beautifully reduced it's thick if you go
with a little more rice on on the bottom
it's totally fine because when we flip
it it's gonna have a nice solid ground
for the whole thing to sit on so there's
gonna be a little note here that says
let cool for 10 minutes great
[Music]
when queer I when we were wrapping our
season on our last day I thought I had
this vision of how nice it would be to
sort of prepare a family meal for
everybody I made three or four of these
which was insane and took me a whole day
to do but when I get an idea in my head
I just can't get it out and I spent like
three quarters of a day in my kitchen
and then put them in the trunk and then
we brought them to the production
offices after we had wrapped our last
day and the crew came back and we had
these like three or four of these guys
ready I just want to eat this guy's
diggin I'm just having one more bite
[Music]